so let's take a look at the solution for
this quiz as defined before we can go
ahead and add the eventlistener objects
to the canvas element for our document
specifying the mouse move and keydown
events to be given these functions
looking at the filled in code you can
see that things are actually pretty
simplistic the event itself actually
specifies client X and client Y as
member variables that we can then query
and print out to the console log the
onkeydown event in contrast is given a
similar event objects but rather than
having the client X and client Y
variables it actually has the key ID
variable which specifies the ASCII value
of the key that was pressed on the
keyboard